dit que passons
pour un monde
montant total ignore
nouvelle expédition des airbags abondent
cette fois c'est le contraire de tagro
abriel est justement la photo sylvain se
trouve pas très loin tu y vas
bonjour
moi je suis gilles maupin le giron de la
firme saint-sylvain une société qui a
été créée en 2017 et qui est spécialisé
dans la culture de plantes médicinales
culture et transformation nous sur la
ferme on maîtrise tout le circuit c'est
à dire qu'on récolte nos graines ou une
bouture on les fait on les bichonne on
les plante on et laisse pousser on les
coupe on les ramasse on est sèche on les
trie et on les conditionne
donc la ferme est classé en bio depuis
2010 cette part l'organisme ecocert on a
toute une toute une gamme assez large
donc ça va de la de l'infusion classique
ou là on les plante sont vendus en
sachet soit les feuilles soient les
fleurs après on a une gamme à thème de
13 po on a une série de piluliers pour
les gens qui sont pressés compass le
temps de m'attarder sur une infusion qui
prennent leur gélules et puis hop c'est
parti on a une petite gamme cbd et puis
prochainement on va avoir deux gammes
supplémentaires une gamme tisane du
monde où on souligne les saveurs des
différentes plantes qu'on met dedans et
puis une petite gamme de cosmétiques
nos produits vous pouvez les trouver
dans les magasins biocoop du département
de la vienne dans les offices de
tourisme
notre site internet et certains marque
et de plex disponible sur le net
masson